we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
skylar henry cbs news washington
we can also tell you this sweeping
requirement will impact 80 million
americans but what does this mean for
our local businesses kate houston spoke
to the las vegas chamber today she's
live in our newsroom with more on this
reaction to breaking news kate
yes well nevada is a state made up of
small businesses so an employer with
more than 100 workers is considered
large here i spoke to kara clark with
the vegas chamber who says many large
companies have already similar policies
in place
president biden's vaccination
requirement will impact large companies
such as envy energy and resorts on the
strip for months the hospitality
industry has adopted new safety
guidelines from mandatory cleaning to
mask wearing and vaccines as the economy
and workforce rebuild kara clark with
the chamber says this guideline will
only enhance what most businesses are
already doing this is just another one
of those policies
uh it's certainly giving employees a
choice
uh in the matter but to require
vaccinations or or coded negative tests
continues to keep that workplace safe
and continues to make it safe for our
visitors and our customers clark says
one concern is where the mandate is
coming from the chamber wonders who has
the authority to create a mandate for
the private sector
i asked clark if the chamber anticipates
any pushback from businesses she says
there may be some but again many have
already put these policies in place or
they plan to it also may influence
smaller businesses to do the same